blunt est prêt
il faut absolument qu'on trouve
quelqu'un pour t'accompagner il est tout
seul non non non comprenez vraiment pour
un naze en fait non
je peux les emmener si tu veux alors pas
ton père te plaît y a quand je les ai
emmenés à la comédie française
je suis pas trop mal passé c'est hors de
question
il ouvre la ddt ils sont tous dans la
couchette résidence jeune homme il
mènerait pas à peu à monter nous prenons
le train d'en face pour endroit au maire
des adjoints
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au maire vient combler mon billet je
suis là bonjour voilà vraiment très
qu'il était parti dans le train le voilà
que vous montez va dans le train
évidemment
sont dans un prêt il peut pas leur
arriver grand chose si au contraire il
peut se passer n'importe quoi ils sont
revenus en cours à sa joie
coups bas c'était juste pour savoir si
vous étiez vient d'arriver d'abord ma
chérie currie vérité dans un trinquet ce
que dieu qui se passe
une voiture folle et vous avez été un
peu oublié de payer l'essence
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai marre vous comprenez vous faites
ce que vous voulez je m'en fous mais moi
je ne lâche pas
[ __ ] il gendarmes temps vous aurez dû
voir vos gueules c'est vrai que c'est
marrant
[Musique]